[Musique]
depuis que j'ai été mordu par cette
araignée
il ya eu qu'une seule semaine
où j'ai eu l'impression d'avoir une vie
normale
c'est quand à découvert qui j'étais
[Musique]
tu a altéré le sortilège qui devait
faire oublier à tout le monde que peter
parker et spider man
et maintenant nous avons des visiteurs
[Applaudissements]
en provenance de tous les univers
seul peter
gêné par peter parker
rappelez moi comment vous vous appelez
docteur autorités russes
ouais nan sérieux c'est quoi votre nom
il y en a d'autres qui se baladent dans
la nature on doit les renvoyer
alors tes mails et moi tout ce bazar je
signale que tout ce délire c'est un peu
à cause de vous je connais des formules
magiques qui fonctionne hyper bien et
elles commencent toutes par s'il vous
plaît
s'il vous plaît démêlez moi tout ce
bazar
tu vas te lancer dans l'inconnu
pour affronter des fantômes comment ça
ils sont tous morts en combattant spider
man
ripert
je suis désolé
ouais moi aussi non
ils doivent derrière voir une autre
solution c'est la seule
il met notre univers en danger
qu'il ne prendra pas le pouvoir
tu es tirs alliés
tu veux être tout à la fois
l'ue vont obliger à choisir
tout est ma faute je peux pas sauver
toutes
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe zahia il arrive
et je ne peux pas les arrêter